[Music]
on this
vote the yays are
216 the Nays are 210 the resolution is
adopted without objection the motion to
reconsider is laid on the table the
office of Speaker of the House of the
United States House of Representatives
is hereby declared vacant oh my it's
over Kevin McCarthy has been out as
Speaker the house taking away his gavl
in a vote of 2016 to 210 house is now in
recess so the Democrats and Republicans
will meet separately to discuss who they
want to have as Speaker the effort being
led by Florida Congressman Matt Gates
who's fuming over out of control
spending and claims McCarthy's broken
promises lawmakers duking it out all day
over what Kevin's fate should be think
long and hard before before you plunge
us into chaos because that's where we're
headed if we vacate the speakership
chaos is Speaker McCarthy chaos is
somebody who we cannot trust with their
word we need a speaker who will fight
for something anything besides just
staying or becoming speaker under
speaker McCarthy's leadership our house
Republican majority has actually defied
All Odds and overperformed expectations
again and again and again this chamber
has run has been run better more
conservatively and more transparently
under Mr McCarthy than any other speaker
that I have served under If This House
of Representatives has exceeded all
expectations then we definitely need
higher
expectations former president Trump
weighing in on Truth social saying quote
why is it that Republicans are always
fighting among themselves why aren't
they fighting the radical left Democrats
who are destroying our country judge
Janine I'm furious first of all we're
without a speaker this is historic
something like this hasn't happened in
well over a hundred years and now what
we've got is total chaos when the
Republicans are playing out their
infighting on National Television in a
historic way instead of fighting Joe
Biden's policies the one time we are up
in virtually every metric as it relates
to the Biden Administration you've got
the Republicans going out there and
showing how dysfunctional they are as
Matt Gates is engaging in fundraising
and I got to tell you something I am
furious there's no question that this is
something that they have been trying to
do for almost nine months at McCarthy's
been speaker and the truth is that
they've done a lot in Congress they've
got a lot of bills passed the fact that
the Senate doesn't want to take them
they've done a lot in terms of oversight
site and you know now you've got the
Democrats this is a crazy thing
Democrats who hate the Maga Republicans
are now joining with the Maga
Republicans to oust uh speaker McCarthy
this is like the devil is in the middle
of all of this chaos and Donald Trump is
right why are the Republicans fighting
with each other like this all right so
Chad pergram is telling us they might
not even meet tonight they may meet
tonight it's all in flux you've been
following this very closely all day your
thoughts yeah you know well the thing is
I got to leave because they need a
speaker you so uh I just got a call from
Matt we're going to meet for lunch yeah
over at his place nice uh I you know
they didn't just it's kind of sad
because nobody bothered to bring any
Clarity to this right I you if you can't
explain or persuade your point without
putting people to sleep you lose these
parties we realize are not mirror images
one wants to win and the other doesn't I
they they shot themselves in the foot
and by foot I mean head uh it's it's
okay so everybody they broke promises I
had to go find out what these promises
were right he promised to use the 2022
Baseline numbers as appropriation
numbers for this year and he didn't are
you
angry he promised not to let bills pass
with support of more Dems than Republic
Republicans maybe he didn't are you
pissed I don't know not to take up a
bill with unan among Republicans on the
house rules committee mcarthy denies
making the two latter promises so who's
telling the truth I don't know I'm not
sure that I care because I'm with Trump
on this I mean we're talking about this
instead of the Border instead of crime
instead of inflation every time the
Republicans implode you just give the
Democrats more cover than Gerald
nadler's Underpants we have serious
issues right here right and instead of
uniting and fighting for the people of
America who sense that this country is
going in a really bad direction we're
doing this I get it it's a historic
event but it's like one of the few
historic events that I don't care about
this has no effect on our viewers does
it make our streets safer no does it
make our borders real again no does it
make our gas prices go down no it's just
Sound and Fury signifying incompetence
and I get I get my sense is this was a
personal thing it's a personal thing
that's being acted out publicly
and you know what it's kind of pathetic
but that's my opinion and I'll be going
now so the speaker Gutfeld yes where's
your gavl we got to shine something
judge can I borrow your gavel yes you
can so McCarthy says it's personal gate
says this guy signed off on Reckless
spending that he promised he wouldn't do
what does ktie p say well Nancy mace
voted to oust speaker McCarthy which I
think was surprising to people who were
watching and and she says it was because
it was about trust and keeping your word
Now Matt Gates is is arguing that he was
lying that he didn't do that what he
said he was going to do but it's a five-
seat majority and Matt Gates is sitting
in a very safe seat in Florida and when
you have a number of Republicans who are
in Biden districts if you want a
majority to win you have to have a
majority and you have to win by a lot to
actually get your full agenda through
and so the Republican Party looks like
they're out of commission Donald Trump
is in court unfairly or not today you
have this happening Republicans ousting
their own speaker in front of the world
and they have no plan right now to
replace the speaker of the house so
which means they can't move their agenda
forward I was talking to a friend who
works on Capitol Hill on the Senate side
who said the stars are finally aligning
with McCarthy's office to get a border
deal done that is dead in the water now
they can't move forward with that um so
there they are if there ever a time to
pull a fire alarm today would Ben I
can't believe they've ousted McCarthy
before they ousted Jamal Bowman but I
guess that's where we are okay crazy uh
I mean we don't even really need to hear
from you Jessica but since you're on the
table go
ahead that rub it in Jessica rub it in
that is not my style no I'm going to
make it really long actually um you hear
a lot about the impossible job of
managing a caucus like this he only had
a five- seat majority that is the same
number that Nancy Pelosi had and she
managed just fine nothing like this ever
happened when Nancy Pelosi was in charge
and the judge is correct in that they
are squandering an opportunity today
Gallup released um their economic poll
data Republicans have the largest
advantage on who's better to handle the
economy since 1991 and this will be the
cycle for I don't know how many days
especially if they don't even go back
and meet with their caucuses tonight
there are 18 Republican congressmen and
Congress women in districts that Joe
Biden won and those people voted for
divided government they said we want Joe
Biden in the white house but we want to
make sure that we have Republicans in
control of Congress this obviously
signals that they made a big mistake but
McCarthy actually has no one to blame
but himself obviously Matt Gates has his
own agenda Etc Kevin McCarthy decided
that he should go on Face the Nation
this weekend and lie about how that
continuing resolution got cut over the
weekend he tried to blame the Democrats
Marge Brandon pushed back and she was
like no no no no no they saved your butt
like they did back in January and it's
being widely reported that if he had not
done that there would have been
Democrats that would have shifted over
and supported him to keep him in control
of this it was a big big mistake that he
did that squandering that opportunity to
hold on to the speakership for I don't
know a few more months um but yeah Nancy
Pelosi hats off to you well it's easy
it's to hold the line when you're a
Democrat cuz you just want to spend
trillions Republicans don't want to
spend that kind of money there's a
divers difference there's an ideological
diversity within our party but we're
unified by the fact yeah you're unified
you want to break the bank Jessica sorry
there's no
un spending Republicans spend how dare
you how dare you no I mean Jessica's
right this the whole spending debate
that that's left the building well
there's only eight that I guess don't
want to spend trillions of dollars
is mad because she said that Kevin
McCarthy was going to work with her on
women's issues and gun control I I don't
know how you got Hoodwinked into
thinking that a republican majority
leader was going to work with you on
those kinds of issues she just wants
attention too maybe the 15 rounds
getting them in in the first place and
the previously failed speakership years
ago we're going to be a hint and a
preview of where way this may go uh
unfortunately and here we are going to
spend days maybe weeks figuring out who
they're going to appoint next it's easy
it's Gutfeld yes he's going to DC right
now on the amra don't carjack me don't
miss tonight Matt Gates will be on La
Ingram at 7 so check that out hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else